all right 6 55. we are following  breaking news this morning it is from  the south part of the valley metro  police are investigating a homicide that  happened this morning it happened on  seasons avenue that's near pecos in the  2 15. we have bianca holman joining us  now live from the scene with an update  bianca  good morning so we're here in a  neighborhood that is near wigwam and  eastern and you can see several metro  vehicles are here on scene matter of  fact we just saw the metro crime  investigative  truck just roll up and we've seen  officers coming in and out of a home  here  on this street on seasons avenue i just  actually spoke with the neighbor and  said kind of you know what time did you  hear noise and sirens he said he heard  some of commotion around 4 a.m this  morning so we're waiting to hear more  details from officers and so that should  be coming up in just a moment and of  course we'll keep everyone updated  online and on air back to you guys in  the studio